tomorrow's arrests surrender and
arraignment of Donald Trump
is of Paramount public interest this is
a former president of the United States
now indicted
for crimes related to his candidacy in
2016. he is being prosecuted by the
taxpayer-funded legal system and is the
epitome of a public figure never mind
just nationally but globally the
arraignment should be televised but will
it be we do not yet know
it is imperative that there be cameras
in the courtroom tomorrow not only for
the reasons I just said but also because
of course Trump is going to lie about
what happens in this proceeding he will
say the judge was so unfair and the
prosecutors and everybody's just biased
and one of the only defenses we have
against those lies is to actually have
cameras showing what is going on the New
York Times Maggie Haberman appeared on
CNN and made the exact same argument
let's take a listen yeah what do you
think I mean if there is a camera in the
room that's a remarkable moment in and
of itself but it could be important to
actually get a clear view of what
happened in that side that courtroom
absolutely and there is a compelling
public interest argument to make it is
absolutely true that New York New York
is is really regressive in terms of
cameras in the courtroom I do expect
there'll be an argument made I'm not
sure what what the ruling will be on
that right but it's interesting I was
thinking as you you were asking that
question you know one of the things we
saw over and over both with Michael
Cohen in terms of trump and then other
people in the White House people have a
habit of taping Donald Trump and they
have a habit of taping Donald Trump
because he spends his own reality and
will contradict whatever people say
about him
a camera would be pretty vital in terms
of people understanding what happened
and not being told that something that's
fake news and in an era where Trump is
saying that all of these reports are not
true I think there is a compelling
argument for it I am skeptical that it
will happen just I covered courts in
this state I know how against cameras in
the courtroom judges are here but I do
think there is going to be a compelling
argument made and even toggling to the
actual trial itself imagine right what
the public interest and that will be and
so will there be cameras allowed to
depict what occurs on the day-to-day
because I think certainly people would
want to announce right yeah I don't know
whether there will be cameras in the
courtroom tomorrow I sympathize with the
skepticism from Maggie Haberman because
indeed
oftentimes there's questions why weren't
there cameras in the courtroom and
sometimes it has to do with well it's a
federal court rather than a state court
and there are different procedures there
New York State also notoriously strict
about having cameras in the courtroom I
can't think of any legal issue any legal
proceeding where cameras in the
courtroom are more Justified than the
indictment of a former president of the
United States so by tomorrow we will
probably know more two live streams
tomorrow the arraignment in the
afternoon and the press conference at
Mar-A-Lago if it's not canceled based on
a potentially forthcoming gag order it
is going to be a crazy 24 36 hours I'm
glad to have you with us